So there's lawyers here really good that Greenpoint branch of the Berkeley goes library for our streets are stories
and his name was Lois wrote that for that city this every
night the city of Los tell me all about
the Clinton
you know about Brooklyn. Well if you go back I may need to hear today.
I live with more on the Lower East Side. And
then migrated to various parts of Brooklyn where my mom and my
father took
me and the different areas that I lived
in different stories you know. It was a different
time when I was younger growing up. I
was born right
after I was one hundred thirty three right
after the stock market crash and President Roosevelt was getting
everybody back into the things building things and getting people to
work it was a different time people were poor but they got together
and there were times when people didn't
have an apartment anymore or a home because
they didn't have the money in the neighbors got
together and made a party in the street just a party they
cooked they sold. And all the proceeds went to the family who needed it
most and then there were other
times when we hosted payroll parties for young men that were going overseas.
You know it was a sad time but it was a good time but the sad time with some of them that became back.
But I don't want to dwell on misery and wonder Well I'm a nice time you know it was
nice people got together people were friendly you get from your fire state you wouldn't have to worry
about anybody bothering you. Nobody called you any dirty names you know.
It
was well yeah. If you had. I think again depressed
and it was depressed and say I hate Bobby Jones I don't like Bobby Jones
but it was Bobby not the Jones family that you know
why and then that would time go all right and growing up I'm
going around. I used to root for the Brooklyn
Dodgers honestly after stabbing flap rice
and trying to hide and sometimes I
couldn't get enough money to get a ticket with like the five sixty five cents but was an addict.
So we my girlfriend and I made friends with one of the attendance
in the L. and he would seek us and
said again we go there like saying maybe after the second or third inning and
bang on the roll down
door. And then he pulled it all the way up and we need again we get into the more case
or nothing. Or we would stand outside I'm Vesper Davin
you there was a gas gas station
there and the boys was with there
are a lobster to hit a homerun. I mean if they record a home
run ball and was from one of the Brooklyn Dodgers you would bring a chance to retire
into. And they would even give you a ticket or they let
you get into the game. That's how it's almost you know that sneaking in
and
acting but it was it was a different time and we used to go
to after the ball of bang it was a bowling alley right.
Ready for some devolving alley flapper standing in most of the
ball play just to go in there and hang out after it. You know conned out some of them went to a bar
but you know the younger ones went there.
Then we went to Empire roller
rink and we roller skate and would be over
there with some of the dodges and we would have fun
but it was a different time it
was I would like. Go back to that time when you're
doing going all day. Let me see I
was in my first thought of knowing about baseball when bat eight nine years old.
And I had to be like thirteen fourteen when I least making it
now twelve thirteen my carpets and I sneaking into the games and going on for
Sam showing the case of morals and I had a favorite baseball player his name
was Peewee
Reese and we had a club at
Brooklyn Dodger club. I was Pee Wee Reese she was caught my girlfriend. Was caught for
relatives
and we were all there and at that particular game
when that Jackie Robinson play for the first time a black
player ever to play
baseball and he played in Ebbets Field and it was a shame what they did to him they thought of
going to make it is an apples and everything in bowling
him and all he wanted to do was play baseball which he wanted in which we
enjoyed by the new it yet the people were crazy.
And they just they didn't care you know I'll call foul language is stuff like
that but he was very reserved and he was
a very very sweet
person. And. Usually before the game or after the
game you can get an autograph from him he would no matter what they did to him you can get
an autograph from him. And he wouldn't say
anything bad but. It
was
a different a different time. Now sometimes there's a lot of a swell place I would say not.
Not still not to good things about them you know. But. Time to
a different. Also when I was younger I said that my grandparents lived on
the Lower East Side.
My grandfather was a janitor. I'm one of the buildings on Clinton
Street. And my mom used to take
the trolley car so he would and I don't get the wings of our bridge
and go to see him get off and see him and he would tell me stories
and there was this one particular
story that always stayed in my mind that years and years ago there was
a Jewish gangsta name Bugsy Siegel
and some reason why they used to sit on the stoop where
my grandfather was the janitor could study and make Roman now.
And he would be with his friends and they would be screaming and yelling
and doing all crazy things on my program follow them and go
crazy doing that and getting him out of there and a couple
of times he would tell my mother tell
me tell them young kind of being young got enough. You're going to be and I
should have waited in line he says has said he was that he was a gangster Knight tell my mum and that's
a little bit I know that my father was going to know once and didn't call me and to
me that it was it was funny and then that
was trying to think that to drive me crazy just
one
actor that my mom used to go over here to the Henry Stu settlement and they used
to have dances I understand they night. And my mother would go there
and there was this one good looking guy my mother told me
that he would have to dance and my mom liked to dance that he did OK show you know if you don't
dance and Haro sister came over and her sister says
Why who are you dancing with to my love this that I don't know he asked me to
dance and I want to do it so I think. Later on my mom
found out he became a movie star.
I can't think his name was tall dark
looking and he just he played in
musicals the money made him why he became.
They had a gangster roles as you know not too good to remember any of the movies
they do remember any of the movies and that isn't always this going. This is one of
those long term memories of going going going but
I could see his face I really could see his face.
And he reminded my mom a little bit about Rudolph
Valentino the sheik that let's see let's dive in film star OK and
all the women used to go crazy you know but my mother God rest his
soul was had a favorite favorite
was
first
me.
And he played in a few movies good looking and.
I can't think of it but anyway my mom was nuts about him.
You can say anything bad about him.
No. After he passed away.
You know right away and yes you passed away. And they did this show on
television about some of these actors and what this that's
this sexual references were and it turned out that he
was gay that only with gay but he died of some kind of an
illness
which was that time. Right you
know. One of Tyrone Power.
OK
OK And my mom was than him but I
have that you haven't even heard now on the number we
which is going number
really well when she found out that he passed away. And what were they were
saying I'm adamant he did sell Na-Na Na-Na she refused to believe that and I said you know my just
like rock I said. But you need a rack of them with eating. You know.
But you know that's how I said I mean a lot of things growing
up different parts you know what were the different neighborhoods that you grew up and. OK I
grew up on through Bhavin you OK with the only Jewish girl in
the competency in All Saints Church.
And used to go to dances over
there used even though I was Jewish I would go to midnight
mass with my friends so I ran services for Easter.
And my mom didn't like it but my girlfriends and their parents you know liked
it and I lived there for a while
and then I moved
to East New York. But then I didn't like East New York at that time
how brazen I was about what I would get
later about I was about thirteen and then I came
back
to he was thirteen when when you. You know. It with your family
or you know well my mom and then when we came back
and because we had been there before and everything you
know on it was not something happened it was a nice little place.
And then later on I met my husband and I got married and moved away from there.
So women went to New York to go live
back there again but then later mining came back and
we moved back into Brooklyn with the Marines where I've been living
in was boarding the same building for well thirty as a result of an
uprising over thirty S. and things have changed.
You know it's not like it used
to their war and now they have this rejector cation.
And I lived on Hooper street Hooper yet Cooper name
awfully couple of times
and. That was a neighborhood that you
would go out after three o'clock in the she you know you you
know that movie that T.V. thing is kind of class. You know your kids they better be
in bed.
Yeah. But now you couldn't go there. Now you can't afford to live there.
That's everything that's turned around and it's just the streets.
I don't know if they getting better or not but I kind of we stand with the state saying what is it that
you miss.
I mean
this becomes I mean shit like people you
know
the
togetherness. You know not everybody is out for themselves. You
know the closeness that you had when you were growing
up the friends. The neighbors.
You know and nobody everybody now was for themselves you know later for you. You know.
Get a good
job you get online help if you have somebody most a money that maybe one
that needs a job. Nobody helps. Nobody books anymore it's all for
one and you. And that's it. And that's what bothers me
because I brought my kids up to my mom.
God bless her she always used to say to me when you're growing up
talk to somebody say hello how are you. How do you
feel this you never know when you're going to need those
people and the fact that you're saying hello nothing comes out of your pocket.
It's free and you'd be surprised to help you. Yes I get help with this Walker.
People come from They'll see me and they know I'm I've got they run right to the door and open up the door.
This is what reminds me of how it was when I was
killing people help
people to still have relationships with some of your neighbors and there is even there's a
lawyer part of my neighbor and I my granddaughter came a couple of times and she
about eight nine years old she says Grandma. Let's go see where you live.
I said. I don't know. You don't know let's go see Ray you know. And we took
the car only drawled out this route back and you know and I've been doing small
between ripple and while about. The house
I lived in was no longer there was torn down was a
lot of what was there that
day and all the buildings around there that I
could go to like they built on Broadway.
They built these Normandy park projects houses very
expensive and that's where we used to hang happy used to be a viral with a cause of
Amman Curly's.
And we used to go there and have the parties with us all just to go after and to go
overseas and
then we party I would act and that's not there anymore. You know. So lots of
things are gone from there to about of our you went to the big dad's
gone so what was that call that was now we can go
to the bar we go to
the roller rink Freddie recessions valving alley the bowling alley and
Empire mojo right.
And Jackie Robinson ever come out of any of those years of the
mill that was a time where it was dangerous for
him because people didn't you know black this black that you know all
the names that tickled him. It was
the period for his life a couple times you know. So he didn't
go but all the other ones we call roll rap
Branca you see Johnny jog and Sendai newcomer
ICAP analysis picture that was one of them was one instance and we used to
hang
out with a ballplayer. And he's dead now.
Raf
kind of used to play for the Pittsburgh Pirates and I was there one day and I was looking for your
I don't know what. As all know I was graduating from junior high and I wanted to get an
autograph and he said I don't give autographs to
girls and I said you're going to be starry and he said
Why so
well because girls are the backbone of the world the country. You know
I says of what simple girls you wouldn't be. So he said I don't give
girls autographs girls should be worrying about baseball things but a house
so I said to him it's the kind you may be a nice guy
but what's going to happen today. If you're not going to get on base.
You're not going to get a base hit you not going to get a homerun you're not going to be based
on ball. You're going to go up one two three is that all nine innings you could be sitting
on the
bench and he was ready which And I said
yeah. And we went home
and I came home and I listen to the radio I turn the radio on
and to hear one thing and he didn't get he was get non-base
that all.
So I called up my girlfriend I told what happened she said that's going to mar was she we could see him.
The next day we didn't go. They were playing the three games that was the day the
day after we went down there.
And we saw him and he saw me I
said you're still not giving autographs The girls share our what
and I said to my girlfriends Sandy said to him you know miss the kind of we thought you were going
I got you know the fact that you didn't even get
on on the real and you're still being a nasty man.
So he says.
All right. Jimmy I'll give you your autograph I says you
know something I don't want to snap. US The way I want
to when he's like them out of the ice and then I want to you know I
was worried that you know my things
do develop a final one of this. Would you like that here any
minute now that I'm going to my plan to go to the game.
Yeah go some of the games and watch it on television. If I can avoid any negative I can go to
again I go to cycles on cycle because I'm in Miami the Brooklyn Dodgers. Yeah you
know and that's you know that's it I love baseball baseball and
football and I get this way a basketball. Because
when I was in high school I was on the cheering
squad team never won a
game a question that the hate was so
bad and I swore after that after that I get that one semester there where I was
I'm not going to be a base cheering on either squad anymore.
I said I hate basketball. It's my team in high school taught me to hate
that yeah
yeah because I never won and never won a game LEGO all but
Travis deficit all these Brooklyn automotive all the
take place to go for a
ball and they number one again.
So I hated this world and you know I have a digression
team with their lives they also share with me about
about living in Brooklyn. I think most of most of it
is I really don't like to see gentrification
some parts. I
mean I would like to have had
it may be tapered off when it used to be
good times to change you know
and
I still like to go back every once in a while I think back to what used
to be.
And there's another little story when I was living on Hooper street. I
don't know you know going into wrestling. But it was a
wrestling star now he was world wrestling champ. Pedro
Morales when I lived on Hope
Street
his sister and brother in law was the
super of the
building and. He had just come from overseas he came from Calais
but up Puerto Rico. He was about seventeen years
old and he stayed with them and couldn't speak English.
Because the
English but he needed a job. So somebody told him to
go and try
wrestling in those days when you
try you get maybe ten dollars if you fall down
in fifteen dollars if you win it was fixed it really was six.
OK what he did
that he did that and later on he became more of a
champ and when but I used to call him Pete sneaky pete.
When there was used to come like he had a girlfriend he liked this
one girl Jenny and used to come
on up you worked on a Sunday he come up knocking on my
door because Dan and I grant used to be public bakeries that used to
sell bagels
and.
One bag of them rolls mostly.
And he would come and he come all the way up to my jaw and knock on my door
and say the least I got bangle you'll get coffee.
I used to make the coffee with them tell me all about his little things how he was he said
I'm working Wednesday he said
but I have to lose. I go why use it because they can't have
too many people waiting for you to do it he makes like twenty five dollars you know.
And then when he became world chair. Well I lost contact with
him. Later on with
the I must say ever you lost the
mirror division. It was a wide the Brooklyn Y.M.C.A..
But they're not there anymore Some say your name is Asia. Owns it but they were doing this thing for
him you know back to Brooklyn for Take
Your morality. And
I didn't realize that you know I had a shop maybe groceries and stuff. And I
started all this and I was going on and all that making this thing but major morality. I go sneaky
pete so and a guy was next to him this other guy. This may be as that's what I
used to call him when he was growing up. So he has you know him arrested here.
So I I says Where is he is all he's around the point I go I yell
at sneaky
pete and
he turn around and I'll sneak if you guess.
And then he came down. You know and he saw why was he
got any amusing
contest and they took pictures and stuff like that and then I met his wife you
know but he said to me I says
to him now you don't have to lay down for nothing. I see that you know. Now I know work.
I get money but not that I don't do anything.
But this you know losing the little things that I had those little references
but I LOVE WITH THOSE ARE ALL GOING TO BE years and years ago going over to the whims
of our bridge the trolley cars. OK They had a child and now when they have
the station.
You've got this on the station with trains go this way that's what they used is
a little little opening all in there and what they used to have over
there was a trial because coming in and the trolley cars comment and
then they turn around to go war earlier man and then they go. Have died that.
They had no walls and nothing they had in the summertime they had bars
on the windows and they had shades. That was your recognition ing you
know what I was different I love the whole I love child they go all over and then they got
the electric child later on that the bus.
That's all it went all over the borough to do or did you write a lot.
Yeah five cents five
cents by cents could take you from here to Conny Ireland that were used to
get your to drive the rise of yet Tony
Island
the stack
law the parachute the parachute ride that they have next by well
that used to go all the way up you want to get them up you feel
in G.'s coming down. And then you had all those other like you had one
Apoc I miss all things I miss this it
was night with night you go
there you had you come from the train station. Like I do when my mom
and dad was inside the train station with all these little places that you come
by commissions and hot dogs and stuff like that and I always used to go
because the guy would have corn on the
cob. And you get more peace accord on the copper nickel and he
don't get how melted
into the hole are so good and then
you would find the guys with the jelly apples
and jelly Apple Apple right into the hot jelly and
you get that and they do it with a cup and that piece is a
coconut and jelly jelly coconut. So it's like a candy
apple two cents three cents depends on the people
saying much but that was good.
It's nice. I don't go to Coney Island in less than. Go to Brighton Beach
and my aunt lived in Brighton Beach and we go there
and go to my mama gorge all the stores and buy all
of the food although there are certain things that the Russians got the right to it
was like you like a blend. Or some voice just something you
know something that would make meat pie and take it home.
You know because that's like the Heritage guys we got we got German Russian
and Hungary and and. And I'm
like yeah. In your family.
We ate all those things out there it was nice you know you made me go down to memory lane and wishing that
I was really back here again. Because their dealings
were so
different when I was growing up by all of them all this is not the thing you guys didn't
know I don't know if anybody of them. Remember it. But you didn't just go to the movies when
you went to New York you went to a stage show.
OK The movie just had the oh the Brooklyn Paramount with the press twice.
To have class A natural as a
guest performer and people used to draw apples intimated that he was
a designer. They didn't say but getting back
what maker he was just getting a little thing any had his
faults high and you could see him forgot about you know he had a pretty good voice but I
think yes when I was Tony Bennett and I did like.
Why the game that's in New York they had the stage shows you had the Strand. D.N.A. You had a
New York. Hair my you had
gone the Roxy to Fox and they would show
movies and a stage show and after the movie was over.
You get a van a
store. Desi
Arnaz man. Tony Bennett you know am I talking that
I'm
sure is man. Many man and what they
would do it they would play and they would have comedians they would have fingers they would have all those
things and
then later on it would go go away and then them. You know the
second set would
come and that's when I used the same to say I used to sneak out of
school say I would go to the
nurse's office say I had a national test coming on and she gave me not to go home and.
I need my girlfriend and go to the. Well that's a good time I
got
I got caught by one of my teachers but I got all the details and
he was taken aback and me he was going to do did you hello.
Mr that are you. I said I'm fine how are
you. And he said I want to look you on sound I says OK so we've got we're talking
Tony Bennett was going up with was going to perform them we wanted you so you get down so he said
that I was this is that it was. When we went back to school and then they would every time he'd seen
me that I had a lot of ideas that and in that so I'm the
most the type that's that's how it was I'm like and I miss
that I miss the camaraderie. You know
the togetherness between teachers and students. Not
the N.B.A. or the hate or anything else. You neighbor S. jealousy I.
People were different and you know you had all types
of you know. Spanish. I went to a lot of
Indian weddings.
I went to a Muslim wedding. I went to a Chinese wedding I went to a Chinese
funeral because all these people we were always like the League of Nations where I
live you know and especially going to school and
high
school and you got. These people
and you know you got to mingle with them and know the
things and I I had made the thing that I wanted all knowing all about other people's religion.
That's what I was worried about and at that particular time I think I know more about
the Catholic people's religion then the Catholic people that because
I went after it in earnest I want to know why you celebrate
this why you do that and just like I expected my girlfriend to learn
about my religion but she didn't do it. Did you learn about all this religion
just from talking to just run or do some You're going like I said I was the only Jewish girl a convict her
nanny and I knew a lot of people
and in fact one time was very very sad and I did among bacteria in
that it was
midnight mass and one of my
friends member of the family was
sick and
I don't my side of the cloth I just stay in the back the last seat in the back
and I used to pray as I own you know nothing the SAMs and everything
else because I knew that I knew was bothering him and why I could say in
Latin what this one particular Midnight Mass I lent him
was supposed to be to
have my girlfriend and her family you know by
prayer and I was sitting down minding my own business
and this woman
that was a week of fava Lou. He came and he
was doing sermon and this woman stood up and she said she doesn't want
to stay doesn't want to sit here. While the heathen is in the
church
and. What he's And what he's a new You're
talking about so she says he's an
end here. And you have to get her out and I'm not going to sit here so he
can baffle Sapulpa excuse myself.
Digging down from the point but when all this to her and that's what I'm talking
about and she pointed to me and he
said she thought Cheney is all what do you pointing at her for what funny
that she Drazen she does them a lot and yet she still
wish he looked at
her and he said yes.
And go up there and buy you all that she demanded across
that he was Jewish too. So if you come to see him.
You come and if you don't mind. Now I want you to
leave. Just tell. How did you
know which
is because I know that nations a know those in
little you know
their first time I saw her when she saw me because I used
to going to this other little section church and I go.
My name I'm back you know long bacteria again never because I
was doing a good thing for somebody. And she turned it
into a nasty
thing and I felt like the church was tainted after a while I
just
didn't know the priest time used to come to my half and tell come
to see me and tell my mom that she's
my mother said look I don't approve of her going to church.
OK Because I know deep down you people are trying to convert her. Did
you tell them.
She said this is hard decision. She said she was
hurt very badly and she doesn't want to go there
again that's how it ended here
she hurt me. Do you really
think you guys all the Is I mean did not you don't want to step right. What
do you know who's not doesn't have to go to church to get up to stay there. To Midnight
or to go up to sunrise services. I could have been in
bed but I ran I went to go show respect for my friends.
You know that's how I learned a lot about those other people's religions all
and going to the weddings because once when I'm a people person.
I like people just don't hurt me but I do and the
dating
is that if I could I would
do lots of things to you
in some people then not like
that you know and
I wish it was I wish it was different with you was it was a different world.
I come home. I go shopping in Greenpoint not come home on the bus and I see these
kids and I say oh please God don't let them be discontinued.
Please do it God is going to ruin this country
the pursing the biting insult and noise.
This is the new generation and it hurts me so much
to
Jesus then not all and not all but
then you got. The stand they did she leans in the schools and people
don't
respect people you know and I was always taught
to respect i taught my children to respect and I hope they take Jill's injuries.
But it's hard it's hard I mean live the
life eighty two years old been there done that like my kids we went to my daughters when
I was feeling very bad her girlfriend came over to me said
we have a marijuana. I go Been there done that I said What do
you think you were vented it. There was another tries to get another marijuana
plant my gorgeous girlfriend. She's going overseas
and she gave me
this. Point I G.'s a lot less can you do you say because you water
it and take care of it while I'm gone. You know about it we should
all Problem was I love plants. I go I
had her God on one side. So he had
his beer and my joy and one of my daughters time was going out with a transit
cop and when he used to work on
the Broadway line he can get up Martha you go get don't exist.
Bring it don't have a minute you know have caught Jim and you spend his
months
down and is one day he came home to my not
adorning come I am making coffee. So I made the co-op easy goes over to the
window and he
goes what stack. That the plant.
Whose is it. I'm minding it in these girlfriends.
Do you know what that is no.
He said you know you could be arrested right now arrested for
what he said that the marijuana
plant and he says and I'm taking it. I said then what are you going
to tell to nigger when you're going to tell a girlfriend. So I
said to him and his name and he says no this is going to be bad of let's put you
in custody take you to the police that I said yes you are you and who
else and then you start to come a little bit my and I my daughter one of my
daughters Kamal's do
you think you wanted to grow one marijuana.
So he took the plant and it was her
I
and any girlfriend came home from a vacation she came
to my house I told Sandy like did you know if she was help when she got on the ninety a
precinct I
don't have it. And she said why I said well
because I was. Richie I said Richie and its friends came up when they saw the plant make
the plant and then about put me in
jail because I was growing marijuana.
So she went and told we laughed about it we had it we have a bad it and then our group will come
out that is I mean watching the house on the yeah me and I have a what's your goal
goal all
your fish it in South Asia was
not sure you know that it was going to come all right.
You know and go and see what it was I don't even know what it
was I said to some point because how come you don't know
why just because I don't smoke it.
I want to know what it is I don't know what the planet the green planet needs water and why.
That's true. That's how I was ready last if you wish it
was
you know just I wish
that
sometimes we could go back I go back
about how many is all
when you reach
a
Pearl Harbor it was forty one the day with
my birthday June
sixth and I were in school having in
the principal called an
immediate audience had to go to
the assembly where you had this the news.
He told us come out and we know about the
war and to and maybe the war is going to be all
over and a couple of went on and on and on whether
the school asked him why. So he said because
the American man. In
France they landed in Normandy. This is D.-Day. This is the
start of the allies
going in I think am I right.
So that a lot. I didn't realize that you and the teachers what I just did
my birthday what a good birthday present I got you know the dress I present
I got my granddaughter was one of my birthday this year. Oh you guys arrested
here is about six months. But that said That's what I would like to do I'd like
to
go for one one moment go back in
time you know what a good
year and a good time
and just inhale it take it all
and you know forget about the hate they get about ISIS getting back to
school being killed the kids being killed people killed
people slashing event just going back you know good. Hot.
Everybody everybody should
have that flour. She just go back
one pot trying to be a life of good time
and that's what I did people wish they wish but just a little but that's what I
wish for that you can go but that one perfect moment in
time when you were happy.
That's a good list right. Yeah that's a great one and we suffer
everyone you know. Thank you so much for talking to me welcome.